USING THE ISAIAH ROBY
HAMPTON DRIVES, GIVES IT NBA DE
DOES SO MANY THINGS WELL ON THE
OFFENSIVE END.
ANTHONY,  THE LINEUP.
A SCREEN FROM
PAPATO PLAY.
WHAT A IN THE OPEN FLOOR.
STEPPING THROUGH THE MIDDLE.
TAPPED THREE.
WATERS -- IT MALEDON. OTHER
CORNER TO THE
QUESTION.
THEY ARE SEE.
THE TWO
REBOUNDED BY BAMBA.
>> Jeff: GREAT PLAY, JUST DID T
>> Jeff: THAT THREE.
REBOUNDED.
ROBY LOBS IT
HAMPTON IN THE STARTING LINEUP
HAMPTON.
DIDN'T HE?
>> David: I THINK SO.
AND A FIVE.
BAZLEY TO THEO FOR HIM. SHOT.
>> David: FIRST TO CLOSE DOWN S
HALF TO PLAY IN ON TWITTER.THE
OF THAT DEFENSE.
CHUMA THUNDER LEAD BY FIVE.
MARKELLE STARTED!
>>
MALEDON.  BUT TAKING 37
PLUS A GAME.
>> FOR THREE. SETS THE SCREEN.
ALEKSEJ POKUSEVSKI, ACROSS THE
CARTER.
THE
83-81. WENT TONIGHT.